en
visite en diable j'ai quelques hôteliers
je l'aurais pas de parler de la du
tourisme bien entendu et ils m'ont
demandé est ce que c'est possible de
trouver une idée quelque chose pour
augmenter la fréquentation des hôtels en
hiver aujourd'hui tout le fait un cours
de cuisine un cours de cuisine pour qui
pour les bonnes causes wife anglaise de
l'autre côté du channel qui vous le
savez bien savent pas très bien fait la
cuisine y est
pêchu
invenergy the same as to be good to make
her des sources
d'économies
c'est pierre faye c'est une expérience
formidable parce qu en angleterre on
aime beaucoup la cuisine française mais
on n'a pas souvent l'opportunité
d'apprendre les met dans la lah avec ça
avec des achats
j'aime beaucoup la cuisine normande je
me fais la cuisine avec le beurre je
pense que c'est très très bien ici dans
cette ambiance est ce que vous vous
sentez plus journaliste ou cuisinière
aux poulinières contre les femmes
on trouve beaucoup de puces et la
cuisine française en angleterre séjour
ici parce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
vient viennent en vacances et prend le
goût pour la cuisine française
une façon plus générale est ce que les
anglais sont très attirées par la france
actuellement
nous avons eu pour information 71 mille
visiteurs appels téléphoniques et
lettres
rien que pour le mois de janvier 72 à
notre bureau de londres des anglais qui
veulent aller en france pour les
vacances donc on peut espérer de plus en
plus d'anglais en france pour les
prochaines vacances armée bien entendu
et on est de plus en plus francophile
enfants en angleterre avec le marché
commun
[Musique]